[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
TIM NEWBURN: Thank you, Chris.
And thank you,
everyone, for coming.
We were just
talking beforehand--
it's a big ask giving up three
hours of your working day.
[LAUGHTER]
No, it's a big ask giving up
an hour of your working day
to come and hear a stranger
talk about a subject that you
may only have just a marginal
interest in, so thank you.
Thank you for the invitation,
Chris, and for hosting.
It's lovely to be here.
So I'm going to talk
about this little book.
As Chris said, you've obviously
had several talks by people
doing books in this
series, and I kind of
imagine that some of them
will start by saying,
well, it's a very short book--
a very short introduction
to a subject.
And the challenge-- it's like
that old thing, you know--
I'd have written you a shorter
letter if I'd had more time.
Actually, trying
to capture things
in a small number of words
is extremely difficult.
And by way of illustrating--
I brought along a visual aid
to illustrate at least one
of the challenges for me.
So I teach criminology
at the LSE.
I teach undergraduates
and post-graduates.
I cover, one way or
another, kind of the range--
not everything, but
broad range of topics
under this heading
of criminology,
this thing that we do.
And a few years ago,
I wrote a textbook.
So I wrote a textbook
for undergraduates.
The intention was to
try to write a book that
would make some money.
It wasn't an
intellectual enterprise.
I've written other
things, which maybe
had some kind of
scholarly interest,
but the textbook,
fundamentally--
I mean, there were
other reasons.
But at the time, I was trying
to make a bit of money.
So I wrote the textbook,
and this is it.
So that's it.
[LAUGHTER]
This is the third edition,
so it's made a few quid.
1,143 pages.
I did a quick word
count on the documents
when I first sent it in, and
it came in at 505,000 words.
So it's expanded
a bit since then.
So writing this thing was
an interesting challenge.
They're supposed to be
somewhere between 30,000,
35,000 words or something.
So it's like a really
long essay or some such.
So what I've tried
to do in the book
is ask a series of questions.
Has anyone here studied
any criminology?
Oh, god.
To what level?
AUDIENCE: A degree--
well, I did a law degree.
TIM NEWBURN: A law degree,
but in criminology?
AUDIENCE: Law criminology.
TIM NEWBURN: Law criminology.
OK.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Criminal psychology
TIM NEWBURN:
Criminal psychology.
OK.
So I'm about to get
desperately exposed, probably.
I was kind of hoping
that everyone would say,
oh, no, I never
heard of it, really.
Sounded interesting.
OK.
But what I thought I'd
do within this book was
to try to cover a
few of the topics
within criminology that I
thought a general audience-- so
in the main, people who
either knew relatively little
or nothing about criminology--
might be interested in.
It might give them
a kind of taster,
particularly if they wanted to
follow it a little bit further.
So as you can see
on the slide, these
are the chapter
headings in the book.
It says kind of things
like-- so what's crime?
A lot of lawyers
in the audience,
I think, so we maybe have a
quick conversation about that.
Who commits it?
How do we measure it?
What's happening to it?
Bit of a giveaway
in the next one--
understanding the crime drop.
How do we control it,
and how do we prevent it?
So I'm going to-- in my--
however long I've got--
another 30 minutes or
so-- scoot through.
I'm going to pick up on
a few of those questions.
Obviously, I can't talk
about the whole book,
but I'll try and give you
a flavor of four or five
of those questions.
So I'll start with
what's criminology--
the main one, I suppose.
So everyone would be
familiar with this.
You're in a taxi or a party and
someone asks you what you do,
and you say, well,
whatever you say.
And I, taking a deep breath
and sometimes a sigh,
say, I'm a criminologist.
To which the kind of
actually quite pleasing
and standard response is oh,
gosh, that's interesting.
That must be fascinating.
Now, the reason,
unfortunately, and the spoiler,
that people say that is
that they've, of course,
got an entire misconception
of what criminology is
and what criminologists do.
And then, of course,
I bore them rigid,
and they realize it's
not nearly as exciting
as they thought that it was.
And the misconceptions
are legion,
so all sorts of reasons,
all sorts of things
that people think
criminology is or might be
and criminologists do.
Certainly, for students, a
lot of the time-- criminology
is burgeoning in
universities now,
hence people being
able to punt textbooks.
One of the reasons I think that
students have been interested
in criminology is the CSI--
crime scene investigation
time things, the sort
of forensics and stuff.
They kind of imagine we're
sitting in smart Google style
offices with all the latest
kind of technologies,
tracking serial killers
and solving crimes
and various other things.
Now, there are probably
one or two people
who style themselves as
criminologists who are involved
vaguely in that kind of thing--
slightly more
realistically than CSI--
but most of us are not doing
anything nearly so exciting,
actually.
Most of us are teachers.
Most of us are working in
universities for some of you
who are familiar
with it, teaching
that thing called criminology.
Now, it's not really a
definable thing, I think.
So I think the first thing
I'd say about criminology
is unlike--
pick your subject-- economics,
social science, sociology,
political science, psychology--
criminology is not
discipline, I don't think.
It's not a master discipline.
Criminology with something which
rests on other disciplines.
So those people who
are practitioners
are all of those things--
are lawyers, sociologists,
historians, political
scientists, psychologists,
and all the rest.
And criminology is
a kind of amalgam.
It's the-- excuse
me-- bastard child
of a variety of 20th
century disciplines.
But its focus, I think, is
this thing at the bottom here.
So there's a picture
of a famous--
probably the most famous--
20th century criminologist,
a guy called Edwin Seville.
He's an American who
worked most of his career
in Chicago, at the famous
Chicago School of sociology
and criminology who defines
criminology as essentially
these three things-- the
study of the making of laws,
the breaking of laws,
and society's reaction
to the breaking of laws.
So what do we criminalize?
Which things do we
treat as criminal?
And why?
And how that changes?
We'll come back to
that momentarily.
What is it?
How do we understand deviance,
the breaking of those rules,
laws, and so forth?
And how do we respond to those
forms of deviance, and why?
And how do our social responses
to those things differ?
So that, I think, broadly
speaking, still serves--
even though it's 80, 90 years
old now-- as a definition,
still broadly serves as
a pretty good indicator
of what criminology is.
So as promised, let's
start with something
that should be pretty
straightforward, and certainly
straightforward for
an audience here.
So the question for us is--
what's crime?
Over to you.
What is crime?
Anybody.
And no right answer,
of course, to this.
But what--
AUDIENCE: Breaking the law.
TIM NEWBURN: Breaking the law.
Breaking the criminal law.
Breaking the law?
Yeah, breaking the law.
AUDIENCE: I mean, theoretically
it's breaking the criminal law,
but how do you deal with
different legislations
across countries?
So [INAUDIBLE] from a British
point of view, but, I mean--
TIM NEWBURN: So it's
comparatively contingent.
Things that we do here
we may not do elsewhere.
Yeah.
So it's the breaking of laws.
But if I'm an academic
who's interested in that,
and I'm simply--
am I simply interested
in the breaking
of laws within a
particular jurisdiction?
Well, probably not.
What do we mean by
the breaking of laws?
Does someone actually have to be
caught breaking the law for me
to be interested in
that as a criminologist,
or is it forms of
behavior that in principle
could be criminalized?
Or what about those
things which don't
reach a criminal threshold?
What about that acronym
that became so famous
on the new labor government--
ASBO-- anti-social behavior
order, not criminal offenses--
causing harassment, alarm, and
distress-- so sub criminal,
but entirely the
sort of thing that
was dealt with by
criminal justice
system in a variety of ways.
Crimes for us, I think,
in all sorts of ways--
and just deal with
this very briefly--
a highly problematic thing, not
least because, as pointed out,
it's culturally relative.
The way in which we
deal with theft, or rape
outside or inside
marriage, or murder,
or a whole variety
of other offenses,
will vary extraordinarily,
potentially,
from country to country,
but also historically.
So what are we allowed
to do, and what's
criminalized at certain points
in time, as we know, changes.
So first, just very
quickly-- two examples.
Something that's criminal
now that wasn't 100 years ago
in this jurisdiction?
AUDIENCE: Cybercrime.
TIM NEWBURN: Cybercrime
because it didn't exist.
How about something
that existed?
AUDIENCE: Smoking inside.
TIM NEWBURN: Smoking indoors.
I love that one.
That's a cracking one.
Tobacco.
So we've criminalized various--
so now the regulation
of tobacco consumption
is really, really tight.
All sorts of ways in which you
now can't do this, and this
is very, very new.
So what about the reverse, OK?
Things that we now can
do that we couldn't.
AUDIENCE: Having an affair
[INAUDIBLE] marriage.
Was that breaking the law?
TIM NEWBURN: Probably
wasn't criminalized, was it?
But we're close, I think.
AUDIENCE: Gay marriage.
TIM NEWBURN: Gay marriage.
Very good one.
So a variety of things to do
with sexual relationships,
to do with women's
reproductive health.
We could go on and on and on.
So when we're thinking
about these things,
we need to be critically aware,
both of historical change
and cultural relativities.
But then criminalization--
so let's just
think about it a
little bit more,
and I might come back to
this briefly at the end,
depending on time.
The creation of criminals.
So I think in a lot
of popular discourse,
and a lot of public
conversation about crime--
political conversation
about crime--
we will use the word
"criminals," and we will--
or I hope I won't.
Some people will use
the word "criminals"
as if there's something
essential about the person.
A criminal is a type of
person separate from someone
who's not a criminal.
So if we go all the way
back to the 19th century,
for those who are
familiar with it,
kind of the phrenologists
who studied, you know,
the shape of the skull and
the size of the forehead--
all a bit unfortunate for me--
but physical
characteristics which
were thought to be associated
with criminality-- just,
as it were, the kind of
historical precursors of those
who now think that there are
a variety of other biological
or psychological or
mixed socio-biological
characteristics which somehow
distinguish the criminal
from the non-criminal.
So are criminals a class apart?
So it's just a question
to think about.
So have you, have I, or anyone
in your immediate family done
any of the following?
And as I say, don't need
to put hands in the air.
I mean, obviously
feel free if you wish,
but probably best not.
Have you or anyone in your
immediate family, including
me, smoked cannabis,
driven a car
with excess alcohol
in the bloodstream,
stolen something from a
shop, or downloaded music
or some other
material for free when
it should have been paid for?
Right.
So would anyone like to
put their hand up and say
that they think that
neither they nor anyone
in their immediate family has
ever done any of those things?
Don't worry.
You don't have to.
But congratulations
if there is someone
because I reckon you're in
a tiny minority, OK, tiny.
Just very quickly-- studies
of lifetime usage of cannabis.
If we do a survey,
representative sample
of adults in the
country, what proportion
will say that they have ever
smoked cannabis, do you think?
AUDIENCE: 50%.
TIM NEWBURN: Yeah, probably
somewhere between 35% and 50%,
so one in three, one
in two, somewhere,
depending on where we do it
or how we ask the questions.
Driven a car with excess
alcohol in the bloodstream?
Well, we don't really
know, but it's--
sorry?
AUDIENCE: 20%.
TIM NEWBURN: Yeah, I'm not quite
sure, but I reckon you're not--
AUDIENCE: Probably
won't admit that.
TIM NEWBURN: Well,
a lot of people
won't necessarily know that
they've done it as well, which
is the other thing.
So if you go to
jurisdictions where
there's very low blood
alcohol levels permitted,
awful lot of people who will
be caught with excess alcohol
are caught with it because
they drank the night before,
not on the day.
And it's, as it were, a
genuine mistake, but they're
breaking the law and so forth.
So the numbers are actually
probably pretty high
if we're taking that
as a lifetime thing.
Stolen something from a shop.
Again, self report
studies-- really variable.
Estimates vary from 20% to 50%.
We'll probably take it somewhere
as being in that range.
Downloaded music
material for free when
they should have paid for it.
Well, we don't know.
There was a well-known
Australian study of a few
download sites which discovered
hundreds of thousands of people
downloading, illegally,
material in--
I can't even remember what
it was-- a three or four day
window.
If you extrapolate from it
and do it very carefully,
it means, probably--
frankly, it means most of
us are breaking that law.
OK.
So the idea, somehow,
the criminals--
this is a simple thing
I want to establish--
are somehow separate,
are somehow different,
is nonsensical, yeah?
We all break the
law, if that's going
to be the thing that
determines our discussion here.
So let's just park it,
and we'll maybe come back
to one or two of these things.
But this begs the question--
because most of the things
that I've been
talking about here,
we've been talking about here--
are maybe not that serious.
Some people would think
they were terribly serious--
probably drinking and
driving is pretty serious.
Some people will think
drugs are serious.
But what about really
serious offenses?
What about homicide or
serious violence and so forth?
Does the same thing apply?
Are there
distinguishing features?
Can we see things
in the constitutions
that make up the
psychologies of people
who are involved in the most
serious forms of offending
which distinguish them?
Well, in some cases,
there's psychopathy
and so forth which may play some
role in very serious offending.
But most of the time, really,
what we're talking about even
there, even in the
most serious offending,
is what we'd call
risk factors, which
is there are certain
characteristics in people's
physical and
psychological makeup,
but also in their social
environment, which increase
the likelihood that
they may become involved
in various forms of serious
offending, but usually only
when those risk factors
are found in multiple form.
And even then, that's a kind
of an increase in probability.
It's not predictive,
effectively.
So we have to be
terribly careful.
So what is crime, and
who are criminals is,
I think, as it
were, subject matter
which is intrinsically complex.
And if I would
want to get, as it
were, one simple message
across from that,
it's that anyone who tries
to therefore persuade you
that our responses as a society
to crime and to people who
break the law are simple
things, that there are somehow
simple solutions to this thing,
are obviously misleading you,
and obviously haven't understood
the complexity of the world
that they're trying
to deal with.
I might just go back slightly.
Criminals are class apart
and criminalization--
that second bullet point--
the creation of criminals.
Who do we find?
Has anyone spent any time--
I don't mean as a defendant--
as an observer or something,
or as a lawyer, even,
in a Magistrates' Court or the
lower courts of any country?
Been to witness?
What sort of people do you see?
Who are the defendants?
What type of people, if
you were just broadly
characterizing them?
AUDIENCE: They're
not very well-off.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TIM NEWBURN: Poor, yeah.
They're poor.
Absolutely.
Our courts, especially
our lower courts,
which is where the bulk
of the business gets done,
is full of relatively poor,
disenfranchised people.
They're the people
who are involved
in these forms of
crime which make up
the bulk of the business
of our criminal courts.
It's important to remember
because that's what our justice
system is doing.
Our justice system is broadly
focused on a certain part
of the population.
Frankly, not us,
[INAUDIBLE] has it.
Yeah?
Most of us, most of
the time, are probably
going about our lives
relatively inured against--
relatively insured against--
interaction with the justice
system.
It may happen to you, but
nothing like the likelihood
that it would happen to
you if you were poor,
if you were homeless, or
unemployed, or whatever else.
So just very quickly,
what rarely finds itself
in our justice system?
Corruption, state
crimes, the crimes
of the wealthy and the
powerful, large scale frauds--
much small scale fraud,
actually-- money laundering,
tax related offenses, health
and safety related offenses,
deaths and injury at work,
the crimes of employers,
and so forth.
Again, just a corrective
to some of the assumptions,
I think, about the ways in
which crime and justice is often
talked about, yeah?
The justice system
focuses on the poor.
It does not focus upon the
powerful and the wealthy.
So crime.
What is crime?
That's what's crime.
What are criminologists
kind of interested in?
Well, there's this--
some beginning to it.
So what's happening to crime?
It's been in the
news just recently.
What is happening to crime
in England and Wales?
Does anyone know what
the pattern of crime
is in England and
Wales in recent times?
Pick your own--
pick your period.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
going down.
TIM NEWBURN: It's going down?
How long has it
been going down for?
Take a guess.
AUDIENCE: The current
government were in power.
TIM NEWBURN: Sorry?
[LAUGHTER]
Since the current
government were in power.
All right, OK.
So since 2015.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TIM NEWBURN: Sorry?
Well, that's what all
politicians will probably
tell you.
But yeah.
But then the other
corrective would be this
is not to do with politics.
Politics doesn't
control levels of crime.
Controls much about the
levels of responses to crime,
but we'll come back
to that momentarily.
So not since 2015, a little
bit longer than that actually.
[INAUDIBLE] another guess?
I'll be [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: 2011?
TIM NEWBURN: 2011.
Little bit earlier.
AUDIENCE: 2008.
TIM NEWBURN: A
little bit earlier.
Come on, be confident.
AUDIENCE: 1930.
TIM NEWBURN: 1930.
[LAUGHS] Very good.
OK, so enough.
Right.
Mid-1990s.
So this is England and Wales.
What's happening to crime?
So far as we know,
and I'm going to--
all sorts of caveats here.
I'll come back to it.
So far as we know, crime rose
pretty steadily from somewhere
in the late 1950s through
to about the mid-1990s,
and then it started to decline.
And according to the main
measures that we have,
it's been in decline
for the last 20 years.
And not just in decline,
but in steep decline.
So if you look at
the general trends
there on the left and the
right, you can see the peaks,
and you can see just how
steep the decline seems to be.
So the question
is, how do we know?
Well, two measures of crime.
The first is what we've
called police recorded crime
statistics.
It's basically the data
collected by law enforcement
agencies-- the police
in England and Wales,
the police departments, the
FBI in the US, and so forth.
So they collect things.
Then, according to
administrative rules,
they divide them up into
different kinds of categories--
the kinds of things that you
then find as criminal offenses
in the courts--
and the measure over time gives
us a sense, on the left here,
of what's happening to
reported crime trends.
Now, there's a whole heap of
problems with reported crime
statistics.
The most obvious ones are the
very simple ones, of course,
is all that is recorded
there is stuff that comes
to the attention of the police.
How much crime comes to the
attention of the police?
Way less than half.
So huge amount of stuff
is never being recorded.
Then, even if it comes to
the attention of police,
will they record it as crime?
Well, not necessarily.
They're supposed to, and
they're supposed to do it
in standardized ways, but
for a variety of reasons,
some perfectly understandable,
some less forgivable,
they don't.
And so it's pretty iffy.
So therefore, in this country,
from around the 1980s,
we used another measure.
We decided that we'd use a
standard social scientific
technique to try
to measure crime.
So we do a survey, basically--
a household survey.
We take a representative
in [INAUDIBLE] sample
of the population,
and ask them questions
about what they've experienced
in the last 12 months.
Have they been victims of
a whole range of crime?
Plus a bunch of other questions.
It's originally called
the British Crime Survey,
now called the Crime Survey
for England and Wales.
It's the measure on
the right hand side
there, hence only
starting in 1981.
But it's broadly considered to
be our most accurate measure
of crime.
And that's kind
of what it shows.
Now, there's a whole bunch of
problems with the British Crime
Survey, or the Crime Survey
for England and Wales.
As well.
I won't go into loads of detail.
I'll come back to one
at the end of what
I've got to say this
afternoon, but as I've said,
it's a survey of households.
So it doesn't include
anybody who's not living
in a standardized household.
It doesn't include
people who are homeless,
doesn't include students,
doesn't include prisoners,
and so on and so forth.
And until very
recently, the interviews
were only with people
aged 16 and above,
so it didn't
include young people
who have very high
levels of victimization.
But broadly speaking, that's
what's happening to crime.
There's America, looks
very similar pattern.
Peaks slightly earlier
than England and Wales,
but it's the same broad pattern.
These are FBI reports,
so the kind of police
recorded crime type thing.
That's Canada.
Just the top line is all
one needs to look at.
It's the same general trend--
peaks in the early 1990s,
in decline ever since.
So this is not something
specific to England and Wales.
This has been watched across
Western liberal democracy.
A broad rise in crime
through to somewhere
around the late '80s, early
'90s, and then a drop, and what
appears to be a
sustained drop in crime.
So why?
Why is crime falling?
Now, I'd better do
this quite quickly.
But how many?
Six quick reasons, possibly.
So one's economics.
Is economic change driving--
well-- the rise and
the fall in crime?
The answer, I think, is no.
It may be having an effect,
but it's not clear, I think,
how much of an effect, or what
the effect relationship, as it
were, is.
So we've had one of the most
significant economic downturns
in the last decade or so,
a period in which crime
has been going down.
If there were going
to be a relationship,
you would expect it to
be the other way around.
That is, you would
expect, I think,
the disappointing and negative
economic circumstances would
lead to increases in crime.
And to the extent I think that
we have reliable information
about these things,
there is something
of a relationship between
economic recessions and rises
and falls in property crime--
not violent crime, necessarily,
again, I think for reasons
that one can imagine.
But the bulk of research about
the nature of the relationship
between the economic fortunes
of societies and crime levels
is, I think, at best mixed--
shows no clear and
consistent relationships.
There's probably
slightly better evidence
about the nature of
social inequality,
or the relationship between
social inequality and crime,
but again, I think that's also
quite general and certainly
not enough to explain
the things that I think
we're seeing in terms of
really significant increases
and declines in crime.
So what, then, about the
politicians' favorite thing--
punishment?
The assumption in a lot
of political discourse
is if crime is out
of control, we're
just not taking it
seriously enough,
and we must get tougher.
That was the political
message of the 1990s
across the political
spectrum in this country
and, indeed, in the US,
for example, as well.
So more punishment
equals less crime,
and superficially it
might look like it.
This is, I think, in some ways,
one of the most terrifying kind
of basic bar charts
you can produce
in terms of recent trends
in crime and punishment.
This is the federal and
state prison population
and incarceration rate-- you can
ignore the incarceration rate
if you'd like for
the time being--
in the United
States, 1950 to 2013.
And basically, what you see is
the numbers of people in prison
was relatively stable
in the 1950s, 1960s--
really up until the late 1970s--
and then it exploded and
rose and rose and rose
at an extraordinary
rate to the point
at which the incarcerated
population of the United States
reached 2.3 million people.
2.3 million people.
So something the equivalent of--
I'm going to forget which
American cities now--
but the populations of
something like two or three
sort of medium sized
American cities incarcerated
at any point in time.
But, of course,
differentially imposed.
Who's incarcerated?
Well, who's
incarcerated of course
reflects who comes
before the courts--
the poor, minorities-- African
Americans in particular.
In specific geographical
areas-- so you've
got suburbs of American
cities-- you've
got neighborhoods
in American cities
where somewhere
between one and two,
one in three, young
African-American men
aged between 20 and
35 are in prison, just
terrifying figures.
So you've got this huge
increase in punishment roughly
at a time, or just preceding
the point at which,
crime starts to fall.
So looks pretty good for
politicians, I think.
But actually, just start to
do some fairly basic things,
and the relationship between
changes in the uses of just
imprisonment, in this case,
is the most serious form
of punishment,
really, that we have.
Some states obviously still
have the death penalty
but only use it
in small numbers.
The relationship between rises
and falls in imprisonment
and rises and falls in crime
is just hugely inconsistent.
Just across the bar
chart here, you've
got states which show
dramatic increases
in the use of imprisonment,
but actually very
small rises in crime,
and the reverse.
No consistent
relationship at all
between patterns of
punishment and crime,
which is not to say punishment
has no effect, but if we try--
or as people have tried-- to
estimate its impact, frankly,
in terms of the American
crime decline in recent time,
the best estimate suggests
the imprisonment boom--
what some people would call
mass incarceration in the United
States--
the greatest possible extent
that it influenced the crime
decline was maybe 10% to 15%.
So the remainder is being
affected by other things--
possibly the economy in part--
but it must be a variety
of other factors.
One possibility, and a
famous one in the US,
is the suggestion is that
policing made a big difference.
Now, the reason that this
got so much play in the US
is largely because of the
so-called New York miracle.
From the early 1990s onwards,
serious crime in New York City
declined, and declined hugely.
So some bare figures
there-- these
are what the Americans
call index crimes.
These are the main crimes that
go to make up law enforcement
statistics.
And you can see that across
homicide, burglary, larceny,
forcible rape--
the declines in less than
a decade in recorded crime
are between a third and 3/4
across all categories of crime.
Or if you reverse it, as
I've done there for homicide,
and take from 2007--
the homicide level in
2007 in New York City
was 18% of the 1990 level.
So by any measure, something
extraordinary happened.
Now, the smiling face,
some will recognize,
is Rudolph W. Giuliani,
two-time mayor of New York City,
and subsequently-- well,
let's not go there.
He hired a man
called Bill Bratton
as his first commissioner of
police for a couple years.
Bratton then went onto
the private sector,
then to LA, and then
back to New York City.
Between them, two
media savvy people,
essentially they stole the
story that the crime decline--
the New York miracle--
was the result of policing.
Yeah, crime is down, blame the
police was their tag line, OK?
Is it true?
Well, actually, I
think the same thing
that I've concluded,
essentially,
about the economy
and about punishment,
probably applies to
policing, which is, yeah,
I think it makes a contribution,
but it explains only
a small part of the picture.
So slightly complicated
multicolored bar chart.
Don't really need to
pay too much attention.
Essentially, what
you've got there
is those main index
crimes again--
homicide, rape, robbery,
assault, et cetera, et cetera.
And the colorful
lines are what's
happened to each of those crimes
in the 10 main American cities.
So basically, crime has
been going down, as we saw,
across the US.
All its big urban centers have
experienced really significant
declines in crime.
But the black line in all
of these is New York City.
And you can see that
in almost all cases,
the decline in New
York City is bigger--
bigger than LA and Chicago,
Houston, wherever else.
Now, one interesting
study, I think,
which analyzed in
great detail what
happened in New York City
said, well, look, actually
the crime decline that
we've seen in US cities
can't be put at the
door of the police.
What the police did
differed from urban center
to urban center, so
it's hard to use it,
I think, as a sort
of simple explanation
for what we've witnessed.
But maybe, and there's evidence
to suggest this is possible,
that, as it were,
the crime dividend
in New York City-- the extra
decline that they witnessed--
was largely a
product of policing.
The particular strategies that
the New York Police Department
operated in the 1980s
and beyond may well
have contributed to this
somewhat greater decline
in crime that New York
experienced compared
with its major urban peers.
What would those things be?
Well, very simply,
essentially, policing
has two major strategies.
One is to do with numbers,
which is a matter of controversy
in this country, and this city
in particular at the moment.
Numbers increased dramatically,
much more in New York City
than in other American cities.
But also, and something
I'll come into momentarily,
depending on time, it also got
a little smarter in the way
it did policing.
It concentrated, it
focused its resources
on those places where
crime was concentrated,
and on those things which were
likely to have the greatest
impact.
And so maybe policing.
Security and prevention
is the fourth possibility.
So there's now something within
criminology called the security
hypothesis, which essentially
says the real way in which we
got smarter from around about
the 1980s onwards was in terms
of crime prevention was rather
than thinking about post
hoc things, like punishment--
crime gets dialed in,
flash the blue lights,
pick up the perpetrator,
stick them through a court,
and then imprison
them, and imagine
we've solved a problem--
frankly, is not the way.
What we need to be
thinking is proactively.
Where are the problems?
What's the sources
of those problems?
And can we do
something about them?
Now, there's something called
routine activities theory.
Those who've studied criminology
may have come across this.
It's essentially a
rational choice theory.
It treats us all as rational
actors, for good or ill,
and kind of says, look, in the
main, when people do stuff--
bad stuff--
they do it because they're
making a calculation.
They're making a calculation
that this is in some way,
however partial
their rationality,
this is in some way worthwhile.
So routine activities
theory divides, as it were,
what it calls the chemistry
of crime into three things.
Some nice little scientific
sheen to it there.
It says there'll be three
things-- a motivated offender--
so someone who wants to steal
something or do some other
thing--
a suitable target-- something
they want to steal or some
train they want to graffiti--
and an absence of
capable guardians--
so an insufficient
kind of variety of folk
out there who will stop
them from doing it.
And basically, it says look, if
you change any of those things,
you're likely to make crime more
difficult. And if you do that,
actually, it will reduce.
So the three-- well,
there are more than three,
but three central
things that you can do.
One is you can increase
the effort that's
involved in crime.
Whole variety of
ways-- so there's
a picture of alley gates
there-- very simple thing.
But British terraced
houses have back
alleys where bins
used to be kept.
People now, as a kind of
fairly standard thing,
have started putting
up gates with locks
to stop people being able
to wander up and down.
We have a variety of
techniques which--
locks become more sophisticated.
We have lights that go on.
We have all sorts
of things to try
to make places or
people more secure,
which doesn't stop someone
from breaking into a house,
for example, but might
make them think twice.
It makes it slightly
more difficult.
Or we can increase
the perceived risks.
The most obvious
one being we can
make people feel
they're being watched,
which is a favorite
one in this country
because we are the
world capital of--
AUDIENCE: CCTV.
TIM NEWBURN: Absolutely.
Does it work well?
Evidence is mixed,
but we don't have
to press ourselves further.
But nonetheless, we can
do a variety of things
to try to increase
the perceived risks--
change the kind of mentality.
Or we can reduce the
anticipated reward.
So there's a picture
there of a train
covered in colorful graffiti.
Back to New York City.
There was a huge problem
in New York City subway
in the '80s and the '90s--
one of the problems--
trains covered in graffiti.
Now, part of the strategy of
the transit police and the NYPD
was to try to do
something about it,
alongside all the other
things they were trying to do.
How do you reduce
graffiti on the subway?
Actually, it turned out
to be relatively simple.
They cleaned the trains, and
they cleaned them regularly.
So as soon as graffiti
appeared, they
took the trains into the
yard, cleaned them down,
washed them down, and put
them back into service.
Over time, and actually
relatively quickly,
it had the impact of--
not stopping-- but massively
reducing the graffiti problem,
the reason being motivation.
Why does the tagger want
to put graffiti on a train?
Well, partly it might be
quite fun, the process.
They're artists after all.
But no, fundamentally
it's about being seen.
It's the tag.
It's the public visibility.
So if you get rid of that, if
you get rid of the pay off,
the argument was,
actually, you'll
reduce the problem, yeah?
Now, how am I doing for time?
Couple of minutes.
So the security hypothesis.
We have become really smart
at doing a variety of things
in relation to crime.
So an obvious one here is cars.
So when I was a kid,
which was, obviously,
as you can tell looking
at me, some time ago now--
I'll say it more
now more strongly--
I knew some people who were
interested in stealing cars.
Stealing cars was
really easy to do.
It was really easy to do because
cars had almost no security
facilities.
So there was a particular
make, and I forget it now,
but there was a Ford, and
it was either a Cortina
or an Escort, or something
like that, which--
certainly the urban myth had
it, and even if it wasn't true,
it wasn't a million miles away--
there were only about a
dozen keys in existence
which would open every
single one in the country.
There were no such thing as
a unique key for the car.
Essentially, manufacturers had
got away for years, decades,
with not having,
or not bothering,
to think about the crime
implications of the business
that they were running.
One of the things that we've
done in the last 30 years,
or manufacturers
have done, sometimes
under pressure from governments,
is to massively change now
the ways in which
cars are configured,
making car theft
extremely difficult to do,
the consequence being a
plummet in car crime--
a huge influence-- a huge drop--
itself being a
volume crime, which
has contributed very
significantly to the crime
drop.
And the arguments and
the security hypothesis
is that actually, if
you stop car crime,
you make young
people in particular
who might get involved
in other forms of crime
much less mobile.
And actually, you then stop
other forms of crime as well.
So just reading
across, the arguments
of the security hypothesis
is that essentially, we've
become, across a
range of things,
much, much smarter
at prevention,
and that, arguably,
is the single greatest
contributor to the crime
drop of the last 20 years.
So a couple of final
things and I'll stop.
There is one problem with
crime prevention ideas.
One major one is
called displacement,
which is that sense of
well, if you make crime more
difficult to do around Victoria
Station, well, maybe people
will go to Waterloo, or St.
James' Park, or Embankment,
or the next one along.
If you make crime more
difficult in one state or one
part of the state, maybe people
will simply go elsewhere.
And so to a degree,
there is evidence
to suggest that some of the time
that is true, but not always.
And quickly, there is
a really famous story
called the British gas
suicide story, which
sounds all very depressing,
but it's very illuminating.
And essentially, it's
a simple picture here
which shows the decline
in suicide in the 1960s
and through the 1970s, largely
as a result of changing
domestic gas supplies.
Up until the 1960s, domestic
gas supplies were toxic.
Carbon monoxide in
the domestic gas
supplies-- an awful lot
of people, very sadly,
opened their ovens,
put their heads in,
and killed themselves.
The domestic gas
supplies were changed,
making them no longer
toxic, with the effect
that that form of suicide,
that method by which people
ended their lives, of course,
declined almost to nothing.
What was interesting about
it though, for the purposes
here, is that it didn't result
in any great number of people
finding alternative means
of killing themselves.
So actually, there
was no displacement.
It was a preventative effort,
and a long standing one.
Now, I'm running out of
time, so I won't do it,
but there is some
evidence which goes
in a slightly different
direction in relation
to catalytic converters in
cars, which again has had
the same impact of
stopping that, largely,
as a means of ending one's life,
but in that particular case,
it does seem to have
a displacement effect.
Three final points
and I'll stop.
Thank you for your patience.
So there's two final
slightly left field theories,
which you've
probably heard about,
which I'll just say a brief
word about about the crime drop.
One comes from the
book "Freakonomics."
Famous economist
and a journalist
who wrote a hugely bestselling
book, he says enviously,
about a variety of applications
of economic ideas to real world
problems, and one of them
is the crime decline.
And their arguments in the book
is that in the United States,
the changes relating to
the constitutional position
of the termination of
pregnancy, so the Roe vs. Wade
decision that was
taken by the Supreme
Court in the early 1970s,
had an impact on crime.
Broadly speaking, a very
controversial argument
is that from 1973 onwards,
legalized abortion
was generally freely available.
Those people who were most
likely to take advantage
of this new possibility
were those women
who were predominantly
in the social groups,
in categories who would be
at greatest risk, as it were,
of having children who would
go on later in life, for all
the risk factors I was
mentioning earlier,
to become involved in crime.
Now, actually, they
terminate their pregnancies,
don't have those children.
There's a cohort
of young people who
would have been more criminal
who now weren't, and hey,
presto, actually, the point at
which they would have started
offending, in any
number, is round
about the point at which
crime starts to decline.
So about 16 years or
so, 17 years or so,
after Roe vs. Wade.
Sounds very neat-- actually
not necessarily that plausible.
First of all--
well, two reasons.
Firstly, that
actually the evidence
doesn't suggest, or doesn't
support terribly strongly,
the idea that,
frankly, those were
the women who mostly
took advantage
of the new legal situation.
But secondly, and I think
even more damningly,
it doesn't apply anywhere else.
So in England and
Wales, abortion
was legalized seven
years before it was
the case in the United States.
Crime began to drop probably
about three to four years
later.
So the lag makes no sense
in terms of the hypothesis.
And then, finally,
lead in petrol.
Lead in petrol is
a fascinating one.
Why might this have an impact?
Because lead in
petrol is very closely
associated with a variety
of behavioral disorders
in young people--
impulsiveness, aggressiveness,
and a whole variety
of other things.
But we removed it, or
it's declined massively,
and it links very much
in the same kinds of ways
the previous
arguments in relation
to termination of pregnancy
with a slightly lagged delay
in the drop in crime.
And the great thing about
the lead in petrol argument
is that it would also help
you explain the rise in crime
as well as the fall
because of the increasing
use of motor vehicles
in the post-war period.
Now, there's an ongoing
academic debate about this,
and, again, all I'll say is I
think the evidence is extremely
mixed on this subject.
Probably not something
we shouldn't at all
discount, but again,
and unlike many
of the things that
I've already discussed,
probably treat it as being
no more than one contributory
element in the
things that we need
to be thinking about when
considering this complex issue
of the crime decline.
So my final sentence,
then, will be
that's, I think, how
we might explain it--
by thinking about all those
things and probably more things
besides, but with
a but, which is,
actually, is it
really declining?
Ah.
Now, the parallel here-- so
a few years ago, the LSE,
like so many universities, is--
well, like Google, actually--
expanding its campus
in all sorts of ways.
We like nothing better
than a new building,
shows the university's
being successful.
Pay the staff more,
I say, but anyway--
[LAUGHTER]
No, on Lincoln's Inn
Fields, a few years back,
we opened a new building.
And the queen, bless her,
came along to open it,
and the director, the vice
chancellor, of the LSE
was there, and two or three
senior academics, a couple
of whom were economists.
And in her very low key
way, in this opening
as she walked through
to unveil the plaque
or whatever, in her
very low key way,
she turned to one of
these economists and said,
I'm interested to know why
you didn't spot that there was
going to be a financial crash.
Was a kind of stunned
silence in the room,
and lots of activity
in later years
to try, then, to explain
exactly what had been going on.
But anyway, this octogenarian
had embarrassed the assembled
economists of the LSE.
So I say this partly
because, of course,
criminologists are prey to
exactly the same things.
If we went back to the 1960s,
criminologists, generally I
think, were of the
view that fairly soon,
this increasing crime trend
that was going on would stop.
And as we became more prosperous
and social democratic,
it would peak and then
it would start to drop.
But oh, no.
Completely the reverse happened.
It rocketed through the
'60s, through the '70s,
through the '80s, to the
point at which criminologists
collectively said to
themselves, you know, it's never
really going to stop, is it?
It's just going to
go on and on and on.
I mean, it may slow, but
then it started to drop--
and drop, seemingly, hugely.
So we're just as bad it seems--
probably because some of
us are economists-- no--
just as bad at spotting trends.
But the thing with the
drop here, I think,
is it's just possible
that we're measuring
the wrong things now--
that crime has changed.
We briefly touched on
it at the beginning.
The big thing here, and I'm
standing in the right place,
I guess, is the internet.
Young people's
behaviors have changed,
and much crime has changed.
Now, there's an awful, awful
lot of fraud, for example,
but a whole variety
of other ICT,
internet-based forms of criminal
or related activities I think
are now done out of the
sight of the criminal justice
agencies that have
traditionally been
responsible for intervening
in these things.
So the Crime Survey
for England and Wales,
just to try to play catch up
with a little bit of this,
is now starting to
try to measure things
like internet-based crime
and fraud and so forth.
And just doing that,
and nothing more,
doubles the level of
crime that it's measuring.
So if crime is going down,
it's going down much less
than we thought.
And at the very least,
I think, probably
we need to think very carefully
about whether it's going down
at all.
I have overstayed my
welcome, so I should stop.
Thank you very much indeed.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Tim, thank you.
Brilliant talk.
We've got time for,
definitely, a few questions
if there are some.
AUDIENCE: Would
society be better
if all drugs were legalized?
[LAUGHTER]
TIM NEWBURN: That's
a great question.
Take a drink while
I think about that.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, I'm not sure
about legalized.
I suspect we might
be a lot better off
if they were decriminalized.
It's probably going to be
the same thing, isn't it?
I mean, clearly the war
on drugs has failed,
and the collateral consequences
of the war on drugs
are extraordinary.
So we live in a time where
some radical rethinking
of how we deal with illicit
substances is required.
There are some signs that we're
beginning to do some of that,
but I don't think that we've
come close to thinking through,
as it were, what the most
appropriate forms of regulation
are--
more particularly, what
the role of the state
should be in that
regulatory process.
But certainly it's the
best example, in some ways,
of the failure of the
conceit to imagine
that the solution to
crime is criminal justice.
The solutions to crime to
the extent that they exist
lie elsewhere.
The issues with illicit
substances, I think,
are to be found in public health
rather than criminal justice,
which is only a partial
answer to your question,
though, whether society
will be better off.
AUDIENCE: I may be a
little bit biased here,
but you mentioned that
crime may not have fallen
and it may have gone on
to kind of tech platforms
and that sort of thing.
Bearing in mind it was
around the mid '90s
when crime started falling,
is there a possibility
that technology actually was
a major factor in the drop
in crime in terms of
ability for police
to share information,
ability for individuals
to protect themselves
with things like CCTV,
alarm systems in cars,
that type of thing?
TIM NEWBURN: Yeah.
I mean, it's absolutely
possible that technology--
I mean, technology
is undoubtedly
important in the
sharing of intelligence,
in knowing what's going
on, in managing risk.
It's also potentially, I think--
one of the things that
I briefly mentioned,
routine activities theory
earlier on, one of the things
that is interested in
is the ways in which
we organize our everyday lives.
Now, I think that the
technological changes
of the last--
whatever-- 25 years
or so-- have probably
had quite a dramatic impact
on the ways in-- well,
they've undoubtedly have
had a dramatic impact
on the ways in which young
people spend their time,
organize their lives.
Some of that may be
negative, but some of that
actually may be very positive.
That is, they-- or it may
be mixed, which is to say,
I think that in some ways,
one of the consequences
of technological change will be
to lead young people to spend
their time in activities
which keep them away
from some of the criminal
opportunities that previously
might have been more
significant in their lives.
So absolutely.
I think it can be both.
AUDIENCE: You said
that maybe crime isn't
falling as fast as we think.
How do you explain
the current situation
with the increase in
knife crime in London?
Specifically, in the
last sort of six months
I feel like it's become a
lot more prevalent, or maybe
that's just
sensationalism, or is there
a more deeper sort
of social reasoning
why this has sort of increased?
TIM NEWBURN: Well, your
question's a great one,
but also the phrasing, which
you recognized, I think,
gives something away
because you said I feel.
The reality with
crime trends, I think,
is we always have to look in the
medium or long term if we can.
So the short term changes are
often very misleading, I think.
One of the reasons that we
feel knife crime is increasing
is because of how much
it's being talked about.
And on one level,
of course, that's
very positive because
it might indicate
that people are taking something
that is serious, seriously.
But if you look at
the long-term trends,
or the medium-term trends-- so
the last few years in London--
actually, knife crime's
relatively stable.
I would say there have
been some recent increases,
but none of that's to suggest
we shouldn't take it seriously.
I think there are,
then, two things.
I mean, one question
would be a political one.
Why the fuss now?
Why knife crime
becoming so newsworthy?
Well, variety of reasons, but
you couldn't discount the fact
that there's a big--
with a small p--
political campaign
around police
financing and numbers
at the moment for a
variety of reasons.
And that would have to be
taken into account, I think.
But the other thing
that's going on there
is that I think at least
some people would argue
that if what seems to
be a short-term increase
turns out to be a more sustained
long-term or medium-term
increase in knife crime, then
that potentially tells us
something about the nature
of the lives of young males,
often young black men, in
some of the worst parts,
poorest parts of our
cities, and what's
been happening in their
lives over the last half
decade or more.
SPEAKER: Great.
Tim, thank you so
much for coming in.
TIM NEWBURN: Pleasure.
[APPLAUSE]